TUUKKA RASK, ALL THE WAY AROUND
FOR CHARLIE COYLE WHO STARTED
THE SCORING WAY BACK WHEN EARLY
IN THE FIRST PERIOD.
COYLE, RITCHIE OUT IN FRONT AND
STOPPED BY VARLAMOV.
KARSON KUHLMAN LOOKING FOR THAT
ONE.
LAUZON BLOCKED, A BREAKAWAY.
CASEY CIZIKAS.
THE GAME ON HIS STICK AND HE
SCORES!
CASEY CIZIKAS!
WINS IT IN OVERTIME AND THE
ISLANDERS HAVE TIED THIS SERIES!
>> Joe: LAUZON HAD THE PUCK AT
THE BLUE LINE ON THE BOARDS, HE
TRIES TO MAKE A PASS ALL THE WAY
ACROSS.
IT HITS A SKATE AND THAT ALLOWS
CIZIKAS TO PICK IT UP AND GO
BACK THE OTHER WAY AND END THIS
GAME.
WHAT A SHOT, RIGHT OVER THE
RIGHT SHOULDER OF TUUKKA RASK.
LAUZON, RIGHT HERE, 55 HAS IT.
HITS HIS OWN MAN'S SKATE AND
HERE COMES CIZIKAS WITH THE
FINISH.
A HIGH RISING SHOT OVER THE
RIGHT SHOULDER OF TUUKKA RASK